Hello?
May I speak to Amanda, please?
Speaking.
Hi, this is David.
I'll be your teacher from today.
Sorry, what is your name again?
I'm David.
Oh!
David.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
How are you today?
Good.
How about you?
I'm fine.
Thank you for asking.
Amanda, it's our first lesson, so can you tell me about yourself?
Okay.
My name is Amanda and I'm 29 years old.
Do you have a hobby?
Yes, my hobby is reading books.
That's great.
Can you recommend me a good book?
Sure.
What about the novel, "Perfume"?
Is it good?
I wanted to read it, too.
Oh, believe me.
You will just love it.
Do you like watching movies?
Of course!
I go to the movies every weekend.
Good.
Let me recommend you a movie this time.
Watch "Fight Club."